my least favorite thing with like ever
coming onto the internet to defend
yourself regardless of how big or small
it is is the argument i've seen it so
many times of like well that's the price
of having fame
yeah it's like it's like you're out
there you put yourself out there you're
famous now so you should just be like
used to this and i'm like yeah no
no this should not be normal still a
human being yeah you're still a human
being at the end of the day like you can
say that because you've never been in
these people's positions right yeah i
mean we're british though so it doesn't
count
[Music]
because i think out of the three of us
the only one who's ever had to
make an apology video i think is just
joey yeah and that was for like looking
back looking back i'm like what this is
the most ridiculous reason to make an
apology
yeah it was whack as [ __ ] so it was when
um do you know the anime yuri on ice
i've heard of it you know the ice
skating one yeah yeah so there was a
massive obviously because of the
of the subject matter of the show and
how it kind of you know plays out it has
a very massive female audience right
even though it is technically a sports
manga or anime yeah so i made this i
made this one joke where i said like no
99 of the people who watch this show
watch it for the boy on boy action yeah
and one percent of them watch it for the
actual sport yeah and uh yeah and
twitter went off
they went off on me and obviously this
is the first time where i think because
of where i was where my channel was at
the time yeah uh i'd never really gotten
that much backlash before because i've
been saying my opinion for years now you
know a lot of hot takes but at the end
of the day it's whatever you know it's
just an opinion of mine but i think i
really underestimated
how far an opinion can go about a show
especially with a dedicated fan base so
i just woke up one morning to just like
countless comments i i get pissed off
hearing you talk about shows
because i think it's cause like i think
the way you talk about shows sometimes
is like dismissive and it makes people
feel like why won't you [ __ ] give it
a chance
you're a nice thing
i watched the entire show yeah right and
i enjoyed some parts of it i didn't
think it was the most amazing show yeah
but i thought some parts of it did
pretty well you didn't like it so then
they were like you didn't like it yeah
yeah and because it is basically you
know a show that is targeted towards a
certain demographic in a lot of ways
yeah immediately people were like he's a
misogynist
he's like he he's he's homophobic he's
misogynist he just doesn't like things
that we women enjoy
so my apology was just
you take it down oh no i took it down
yeah i took it down but like uh you know
in hindsight that was it was completely
unnecessary because i think that's the
moment i uploaded it and then i realized
when i read the comments of that apology
video like 90 percent of them were like
dude you didn't have to pause well the
first time the first time you get like a
i guess a bunch of hate overnight in one
go is probably the the scariest yeah
yeah and for me that was the first time
where like i just woke up and it was
just like all these new people who are
just like giving me [ __ ] and just
calling me names and i'm like [ __ ] this
is the end of my career i'm [ __ ] right
so i feel very pressured oh yeah
absolutely so i took action and then
immediately after i uploaded that video
and i started to see the first wave of
comments of dude it's fine you didn't
have to apologize for that immediately
took it down and i realized that was a
big mistake i shouldn't have apologized
yet so now i know if i say an opinion
i don't give a [ __ ]
i just like looking back i just i just
find it funny like especially with how
many people have made apology videos
yeah now it's just like you you look at
you look at the list and you're just
like oh what did you apologize for oh
you know i ran like a cs go gambling
scam yeah oh you know i was i i said i
said like i came on my cat oh what did
you appreciate it for oh you know i just
[ __ ] on yuri on ice
i was like so what did you say yeah
yeah yeah so like but but you know again
like at that time i had no idea right
and because again i think i was just
like pressured into thinking oh maybe
i'm the bad guy because of this mass
audience of people online who were
saying how [ __ ] i was as a person for
giving this opinion yeah so i think i
mean obviously now i know because i've
experienced that and i've obviously
heard from other people's experiences
and whatnot but i think initially yeah
it was uh it means people are engaging
with your opinion no it's just good
because sometimes that means they're
getting angry but at least they're
engaging that's all that matters exactly
and i think
you partner manager
we've seen like an uptick
whatever you did in that video
but wouldn't it be even worse if nobody
gave a [ __ ] about what you said
i mean
are you saying it's just the curse of
being popular
is that what you're saying of if you
have opinions that's what comes with
faith
i said i don't like some animals people
get really annoyed about it but it's
like you're wrong
i think is a you know that's like a
subject people are very passionate you
think so right you think so you tell us
later about your opinions we'll get
angry yeah yeah
um i actually think this whole thing is
such an interesting premise like talking
about apology videos and whether or not
you regret them have you made it
oh i've made wait what did you make
how many apologies have you heard how
crazy my life i made a party video where
i apologize i apologize about like four
things okay right
wait when was this
um this was like at the peak of like all
the videos and all that everything way
before the pandemic and among us
actually not before maybe it was right
at the beginning right right um and
there are some things that i apologize
for that i absolutely stick by yeah so
what happened can i can you tell
i don't remember any of this
i don't know i just watched if you don't
remember it's fine that just means it
wasn't important
yeah tldr well what what do you guys
know
i guess i know people angry at you but i
never understood why yeah
i
remember like different zones like leafy
made nine videos in a row about you or
some [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah leafy made a lot of
videos right yeah i guess the issues
with
a lot of the things that people are mad
at me about is
it gets taken out of context so far and
then snowballed into one tidbit and then
like that's the thing that stinks for
people this is why i hate her because of
this yeah but like you don't know the
context regarding nothing whatsoever
yeah which is probably like one of the
things that not to retract the apology
but like in hindsight i don't know if it
made as much sense to apologize but i
apologize about this one thing yeah you
guys about it yeah there was this guy
who when those kind of videos were
popular also made a video about me um
like
legit just [ __ ] on me like that's it
but actually the thing is like i was
used to people [ __ ] on me at that
point what really pissed me off about
his video which i was what which i
didn't watch the whole thing but i was
watching through some of it on stream oh
this horse batman i know
bad call back
i was new
only seven years ago
it's tough because like initially it's
like i would ignore all of this and then
i realized like
you need to respond in order to give
people something to respond
and then trying to find that middle
ground of like don't give everything
attention but give the right amount of
attention at the right time to the right
yes yeah it's hard you have a right to
defend yourself yeah yeah so uh when
someone had linked me this and i was
like skimming through it i saw that he
was pulling up like random people's
images that had photos with me at like
meet and greets or on their icons or
whatever
and then he was speaking negatively
about how they look in his video
as he's a v tuber by the way like he's
not showing his face right
[ __ ] on my fans for how they look
yeah so again it was like a a guy
talking about me and it's like you know
you can say whatever about me it's not
gonna be the first time that i hear it
yep yep but for you to pull up
photos of fans of mine and then for some
reason be talking about how they look in
front of your whole audience yeah yeah
yeah and
like you know i do put myself out there
so maybe you can justify talking about
me right but these people and i know
like if you're not a public figure that
type of scrutiny yeah on a wide scale
like you just don't know how that might
impact oh yeah yeah yeah it [ __ ] with
you exactly i was just like this is
so wrong beyond belief and obviously
like i was very passionate in that
moment yeah um and then i was like
scrolling through the video and i saw
that like the video was sponsored and i
basically made a comment about like
i cannot possibly understand why a
sponsor would watch a video not about
someone talking about me you know
there's plenty of those and obviously
like um
commentary type of videos deserve to be
sponsored obviously right yeah but
i was wondering like did they really
watch through this and see him [ __ ] on
someone for how they look like how much
they weigh or like whatever it is
and they thought that like this was good
content to like enable in a sense
because when you sponsor something like
you know you're promoting that type of
content yeah yeah a lot of brands don't
give a single [ __ ] though yeah just like
i want to be on anything that gets us a
million views i i don't know i can't
tell you right yeah i remember did you
end up did you take the video down
initially i can't remember
no okay i can't remember i was trying to
oh yeah no no no no it was just cause
you said the sponsor comment yes yeah
i've never taken a video down of someone
talking about me
i took a video down once of someone who
screenshotted my tweets without saying
anything because i was like oh i just
don't i deleted the tweets
out there and then people like she takes
down videos of people talking about i've
never in my life done that because i
recognize especially as a content
creator like someone puts effort into
something and puts it out there you have
no right
or you have no rights over that yeah
yeah yeah that's one thing the internet
is very sensitive you can't take down
people's stuff yeah exactly exactly um
so anyways i had just made that comment
on stream where i was like
i can't understand from a business
perspective why you would want your name
on content like that and i said like i
would never work with that company right
but then people spun that into me trying
to take this guy's sponsor from him
right right which i understand
especially because i think the
uh commentary community rightfully so is
like
a little uh like a little bit concerned
about that stuff because their videos
get demonetized easily yeah yeah yeah um
so i i understand the concern yeah but i
feel like it was a little bit out of
context because the issue was really
just with what he was doing i think if
it happened now if you had had the same
thing had happened now with the same
public sentiment now i don't think it
would it would have turned out that way
it was because that's crazy to me
because like i i think hearing from your
perspective like what's frustrating
about the situation is that
i think you had a very genuine point
where you know if you're gonna if you're
gonna dunk on like pokemane or whatever
then just leave people leave your fa
leave her fans out of it whoever like
who have nothing to do with the online
internet lifestyle or anything like that
yeah you're saying that like you
wouldn't take a response i'd be like
yeah [ __ ] take it off yeah dude i'd
be like [ __ ] them yeah dude this guy's
an [ __ ] yeah yeah and it seems
unfortunate that because you made that
statement afterwards it almost seemed
like it discredited everything you said
before which was like a genuine point
because you know i i i can't see what
how you know how people can
see it in a way where you it seemed like
you were trying to take this guy's
sponsor
uh because he was in the heat of the
moment everything like that but that
doesn't really discredit everything that
you said before about the video about it
yeah yeah so i was actually just like i
understand and like i apologize because
i would never want to impact someone
else's livelihood for sure and i still
stand by that like i wouldn't want to
yeah but i also stand by the fact that i
disagree with what he was doing yeah
yeah and i don't think that is okay well
it seemed like at that point it got to a
point where did you even know what you
needed to apologize for because it
seemed
like like like genuinely because
it seemed like at that time i was just
like i don't even know why people are
mad at pokemane at this point it just
seems like people are looking for
anything to be bad it's just something
like domain like you know
fun things yeah
it's like man i'm bored today what
should we do
on pokemon yeah
why dude i'm so glad for the last like
two
years with like among us and being more
mainstream and yeah yeah
younger and more female fans like
i feel like uh more of a human being
like i'm treated a little more fairly
because i feel like now there's
a stronger group of people who are
willing to like stand up for my side of
things yeah yeah i'm i'm less so like an
anomaly per se like this this i felt
very objectified during that time in the
sense that um people were speaking of me
as if i wasn't a real person right um
but now i feel like
there are people who like relate to me
enough and obviously i've continued to
make content so yeah yeah you can build
fans over a long period of time thank
you so much
oh thanks to among us
nothing makes me feel more human than
when i'm playing among us who's my
friends this is how you said thanks to
your mongoose i now have my life back
and i i like to thank among us
has changed the game
of a more diverse audience nothing is
done more for women than among us
us all civilized spaces
like what's done more for feminism than
suffragettes or among us
women actually well personally
because think about it because women
women actually got the right to vote
their voices were finally hurt
every vote mattered
right off the creation of the game we
didn't have to wait a few patches
always from day one day one day one
weekend
oh my god
i do find it so funny like i've talked
to a few streamers now and everyone
talks about this among us period yeah
like it's like
it's like a unicorn it's like everyone's
spotted bigfoot like everyone talks
about among us like it was
the golden age of twitch